>> Laura: THE AHS SECRETARY WILL
BE UNVEILING THE POLICY.
COMING UP, A HIGH DIVE OFF THE
DEEP END.
HIS PIECE ON WEDNESDAY WAS
HEADLINED TRUMP IS NO LONGER THE
WORST PERSON IN GOVERNMENT.
NO.
NOT SCOTT PRUETT, NO.
IT'S VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
LOW KEY, SELF-EFFACING AND LOYAL
MIKE PENCE, HOW COULD THAT BE?
GEORGE WILL HAS A CON FISHCY
GEORGE WILL HAS A CON FI CCY
GEORGE WILL HAS A CON FI CONSPIR
GEORGE WILL HAS A CON FI CONSPIC
GEORGE WILL HAS A CON FI CONSPI.
HE COULD BECOME THE MOST
REPULSIVE FIGURE.
TRUMP PICKED PENCE BECAUSE
AMERICA WOULD HAVE SUCH
REVULSION FOR HIS VP, IT WOULD
TAKE THE HEAT OFF THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF.
WHAT MAKES PENCE SO REPULSIVE?
WILL CITED THE POST CALCULATIONS
THAT DURING A CABINET MEETING
PENCE PRAISED TRUMP ONCE EVERY
12 SECOND FOR THREE MINUTES WITH
SUCH COMMENTS AS, QUOTE, I AM
DEEPLY HUMBLED.
HE DOESN'T FIND THE HUMILITY
REPULSIVE, HE SEEMS TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF ISSUE WITH PENCE'S FACE.
THE FAVORITE PINUPS, THE SPIRIT
AND THE VICIOUS PORTION REQUIRE.
WILL WAS OFFENDED THAT PENCE
WOULD CALL HIMSELF HONORED BY
THE PRESENCE OF FORMER SHERIFF
JOE APIYO.
HE CALLED HIM A TIRELESS
CHAMPION OF THE RULE OF LAW.
ACCORDING TO THE REPULSIVE
HUMILITY, RESPECT FOR THE LAW,
MAKE HIM THE AUTHENTIC VOICE OF
TODAY'S REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WELL, THE ACCUSATIONS WERE
PICKED UP BY THE FEEDBACK LOOP
ON THE LEFT AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SMEAR THE VICE PRESIDENT.
>> WHO IS MIKE PENCE?
I DON'T KNOW.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE CORE
CONVICTS OR BELIEFS BEYOND
WHATEVER DONALD TRUMP DECIDED
THEY ARE.
>> HE'S STRIKING THIS BALANCE,
TRYING TO BE THE MAN THAT WILL
INHERIT THE MANTLE OF TRUMP.
>> THERE ARE TWO VICE
PRESIDENTS.
THOSE ACCUSED OF BEING OUT FOR
THEMSELVES THAT THEY ARE NOT
SERVING THE PRESIDENT WHO PICKED
THEM AND THOSE ACCUSED OF BEING
SLAVISHLY LOYAL LAP DOGS.
MIKE PENCE DECIDED TO BE THE
LATTER.
>> HE IS A TITANIC FRAUD.
HE'S THE MOST OF ALL THE
CULTISTS IN THE CABINET.
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN SUCH
SLOBBERINGER
SLOBBERING IN THIS COUNTRY THAN
WE DO WITH MIKE PENCE.
>> Laura: CONSIDER THE SOURCE,
MY FRIEND.
IS PENCE REALLY THE WORST PERSON
IN GOVERNMENT?
WHY ARE THE PENCE HATERS LASHING
OUT NOW?
IT'S INTERESTING.
LET'S ASK MARK LOTTER, AND
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ACTIVIST, CHRIS
HAN.
MARK, LET'S GO TO YOU.
I HAVE KNOWN MIKE PENCE WHEN HE
WAS IN CONGRESS.
I FOUND THAT FROM GEORGE WILL
REALLY SAD.
HE'S HAD AN UNBELIEVABLE CAREER
AS ONE OF THE PREMIER
COLUMNISTS, WRITERS IN THE
UNITED STATES, HE DOESN'T LIKE
DONALD TRUMP, THAT'S FINE.
BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS FILLED WITH
SUCH LOW BLOWS.
I WASN'T EVEN ANGRY ABOUT IT.
I WAS SAD ABOUT IT.
>> IN 1986 HE WROTE A COLUMN
CALLED THEN VICE PRESIDENT
GEORGE BUSH A LAP DOG.
HE WOULD GO ON TO BE A
TRANSFORMATIONAL PRESIDENT.
HE HAS A PROBLEM WITH VICE
PRESIDENTS WHO SERVE PRESIDENTS
OF THE UNITED STATES.
TO GET TO USE A BASEBALL TERM I
KNOW GEORGE WOULD LIKE, THE BEST
PLAYERS IN THE WORLD MISS SEVEN
OUT OF TEN TIMES.
HE STRUCK OUT IN THE DIRT.
>> Laura: THERE WERE OVERTONES
IN THIS COLUMN.
HE WAS PICKED UP BY MEDIA
FIGURES.
HE TALKS ABOUT HOW HE GENUFLEX
AT THE ALTER.
IT SEEMED CONDESCENDING ABOUT
MIKE PENCE'S FACE, QUESTIONING
HIS FACE, YOU ARE NOT A REAL
QUESTION.
HE DIDN'T WRITE THAT.
YOU CAN READ BETWEEN THE LINES.
I LIKE GEORGE WILL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T LIKE HIM.
I HAVE KNOWN HIM FOR A LONG
TIME.
IT PAINS ME TO SAY THIS, BUT I
THOUGHT THE COLUMN WAS BENEATH
HIM AND FILLED WITH LOW BLOWS
AND NOT AT ALL IN ANY WAY
ILLUSTRATIVE OF THE MAN WHO MIKE
PENCE IS.
HE'S A WONDERFUL PERSON AND I
THINK A VERY EFFECTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> THE COLUMN GOT PICKED UP
BROADLY BECAUSE THE VICE
PRESIDENT DECIDED TO PLAGIARIZE
RICHARD NIXON.
WHILE I DO THINK THE TONE WAS
HARSH, IT'S NOT LIKE GEORGE WILL
SAID HIS OPINION DOESN'T MATTER
BECAUSE HE'S ABOUT TO DIE, WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN SAID
INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE THESE
DAYS.
WE GOT TO BACK OFF ON THIS IS
SUCH A BAD THING.
THE VICE PRESIDENT IS THE
BOOT-LIQUOR IN CHIEF IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
HE PRAISES THE PRESIDENT, HE
KISSES HIS BUTT.
WHAT'S SAD, IN TO 20 THIS
PRESIDENT WILL DROP HIM FROM THE
TICKET BECAUSE THIS PRESIDENT
CARES ABOUT RATINGS.
WHO HE PICKS AT THE CONVENTION
WILL BE THE BIGGEST RATINGS
NIGHT OF THAT WEEK.
MR. PENCE, YOU MIGHT WANT TO
STAND UP TO THIS PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE'S NOT GOING TO STAND
BY YOU IN THE END.
>> Laura: WERE YOU CONCERNED
ABOUT VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
TAKING ON OBAMA?
I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER, WAIT, HE
NEVER DID.
WHEN DID VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
TAKE ON OBAMA FOR CREWING UP THE
HEALTHCARE WEBSITE, FOR HOUNDING
PEOPLE WHO APPLIED FOR IRS
STATUS.
WHEN DID BIDEN COME OUT AND
CHALLENGE OBAMA'S ABUSE OF
POWER?
NEVER.
WHY GO AFTER MIKE PENCE.
YOU DIDN'T CRITICIZE BIDEN
BECAUSE HIS ROLE IS TO SUPPORT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> WHY IS MIKE PENCE BEING
ATTACKED?
IT'S ABOUT PRIDE AND EVE GO OF
THESE NEVER-TRUMP WRITERS.
THEY CAN'T ADMIT THE AAGAIN
TODAY IS THE MOST CONSERVATIVE
AGENDA.
MIKE PENCE, A MAN WITH A 99%
VOTING RECORD, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HE EVER GOT WRONG, BUT HE GOT
ONE THING WRONG, ONE TIME, IN
ALL THE TIME IN CONGRESS, YOU
GET ATTACKED BY THESE PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY THINK WE ARE
DEPLORABLE.
THEY DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
MORAL STANDING TO MAKE THE CASE
THAT WHAT DONALD TRUMP IS DOING
IS THE RIGHT THING.
>> Laura: WHEN HILLARY TALKED
ABOUT THE BASKET OF DEPLORABLES.
GEORGE WILL, IN THIS MOMENT, HAS
MORE IN COMMON WITH THEIR VIEW
OF MIDDLE AMERICA FROM WHERE
MIKE PENCE CAME THAN HE DOES
WITH THE CONSERVATIVE VOTERS
ACROSS AMERICA WHO SAID WE ARE
ARE GOING TO TAKE SOMEBODY WHO
TAKES A WRECKING BALL.
IT'S UNBECOMING.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ARE
HORRIBLE, AWFUL, RACIST,
TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
REALLY?
GOOD LUCK BUILDING A MOVEMENT ON
THAT DAY.
>> THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
THIS HAPPENED.
SAME THING HAPPENED IN 1980 WHEN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TURNED THEIR
BACK ON THE REPUBLICANS.
THEY DID IT IN PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND THE ELITISTS CAN'T GET OVER
IT.
>> Laura: TRUMP DOESN'T KEEP A
THEY SORRIES BY HIS BED.
IT'S THE SEVEN SYLLABLE WORDS.
I LIKE THAT.
BUT GO AHEAD, CHRIS.
MY CONCERN HERE IS THAT THE
TIMING OF THIS IS CURIOUS, THEY
ARE STRIKING OUT ON TRUMP.
TRUMP'S NUMBERS ARE GOING UP.
THEY THINK THEY CAN GET
SOMETHING ON PENCE.
TRUMP'S NUMBERS ARE IMPROVING
BECAUSE THE RESULTS ARE THERE
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> NOBODY IS GOING TO BASE THEIR
NUMBERS ON TRUMP ON WHAT PENCE
IS DOING.
I THINK GEORGE WILL HAD A
FEELING ABOUT MIKE PENCE BASED
ON WHAT HAPPENED IN ARIZONA WHEN
HE WENT OUT THERE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE REASON TO
THINK JOE IS SOMEBODY WHO NOT BE
TOUTED BY THE VICE PRESIDENT OR
THE PRESIDENT.
HE DISOBEYED A COURT ORDER WHAT
HE DID WAS RACIST.
SO I THINK GEORGE WILL SEES
THAT.
THIS IS NOT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, THIS IS NOT THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT HE GREW UP
WITH.
HE WOULD LIKE TO SEE MIKE PENCE
BE THE BACKBONE TO
CONSERVATIVISM.
MIKE PENCE HAS BEEN A
CONSERVATIVE ALL HIS LIFE.
SO IF HE'S BECOMING MORE LIKE
DONALD TRUMP, THEN CONSERVATIVES
WILL HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT.
THAT'S WHAT HE WAS LASHING OUT
ABOUT IT.
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT
IT, YOU BETTER SAY SOME CRAZY
THINGS.
>> YOU ARE GOING GOOD.
ALL I WOULD SAY THIS, DO WE WANT
TO WIN OR DO WE NOT WANT TO WIN?
IF THE PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT
WINNING.
CONSERVATIVES ARE GETTING MORE
DONE.
WE ARE IN A WINDOW --
>> Laura: AZAR IS GOING TO BE
BIG.
HE CLERKED WITH ME.
HE COULD HAVE BEEN A CABINET
SECRETARY.
HE'S DOING THIS BECAUSE WE GOT
TO GET THIS PRESCRIPTION DRUG
STUFF, THIS HAS TO BE TACKLED.
HE WILL DO A LOT MORE.
THESE -- HOLD ON, CHRIS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE OF REAL
SUBSTANCE WHO ARE DOING REALLY
HARD WORK.
I THINK IT REALLY URKS PEOPLE.
WHEN STEVE SCHMIDT, BECAUSE HE
RAN A GREAT CAMPAIGN WITH
PAILEN.
>> WE HAVE LISTENED TO THIS GUY
FOR MANY YEARS ON HIS MORAL HIGH
HORSE.
ASSAULTING THE DIGNITY OF GUY
PEOPLE, ACROSS THE BOARD.
HIS MORAL PREENING IS FAMOUS
THROUGHOUT THE LAND.
>> Laura: HE JUST SWORE IN A GUY
AMERICAN TO BE A NEW AMBASSADOR
TO GERMANY.
SO IF YOU ARE A FAITHFUL
CHRISTIAN AS HE IS, HE'S, BY
NATURE HOMOPHOBIC.
YOU CAN'T DISAGREE.
IT'S A LITANY.
>> HE PANDERS TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMOPHOBIC.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT THING
FOR THE COUNTRY, THE
ADMINISTRATION AND AMERICA.
LOOK AT THE TIMING.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLLS, IT'S
THE RIGHT TRACK, WRONG TRACK,
IMPROVING.
TRUMPS NUMBERS GET BETTER.
YOU KNOW THE ONLY PLACE HE'S
WEAK?
FOREIGN AFFAIRS.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE SEEING IS
THIS BIG BLUE WAVE IS STARTING
TO GO AWAY.
>> Laura: CHRIS, I WANT TO PLAY
A BYTE FROM NICOLE WALLACE.
>> WHY CAN'T YOU SAY IF HE SAYS
THAT, SHE WILL BE FIRED.
>> Laura: HOW DO YOU RESIST THE
TEMPTATION TO RUN UP AND RING
HER NECK?
SHE SAID IT'S GETTING TO HER,
USED POORLY CHOSEN WORD.
FOR THAT I'M SORRY.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
COMMENT MADE BY STADLER.
IT WAS MADE IN PRIVATE.
>> WELL, HOLD ON A MINUTE, GUYS.
YOU KNOW, LOOK, MATT, MATT,
NICOLE APOLOGIZED, THE WHITE
HOUSE SHOULD APOLOGIZE ABOUT THE
AMERICAN HERO.
I DON'T KNOW WHY?
JOHN McCAIN, I DON'T AGREE
WITH JOHN McCAIN ON A LOT OF
THINGS, HE IS A HERO.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
IN A PRIVATE MEETING.
NONE OF US KNOWS.
>> THEY ADMITTED IT.
>> I THINK JOHN McCAIN
DESERVES HIS PEACE AND QUIET.
BUT HE STILL HAS A VOTING
RECORD.
IT'S OKAY TO TALK ABOUT IT AND
OKAY TO TALK ABOUT HIM OPPOSING
THE PRESIDENT'S NOMINEE.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW WHAT JOHN
McCAIN SAID?
>> MATT, SO MUCH RHETORIC THAT
NEEDS TO CALM DOWN, IT START AT
THE TOP, STARTS WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> NOW YOU ARE GOING TO
ATTACK --
>> Laura: WELL, I THINK CHRIS,
CHRIS, WE CAN GO BACK AND I CAN
CHERRY PICK THE BRIGHT LIGHTS OF
THE LEFT AND THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY AND MEDIA, NOW WE ARE
THREATENING TO CHOKE PEOPLE.
WE ARE GOING TO BLOW THE WHITE
HOUSE UP.
IF WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
VITREAL, CHECK OUT MY TWITTER
FEED.
>> AND MINE.
>> Laura: DON'T PRETEND TO BE
LIKE THESE SHRINKING VIOLETS.
JOHN McCAIN IS A HERO.
HE DISAGREED WITH THE PRESIDENT.
HE SAID DON'T FEEL SORRY FOR ME.
I'M GOING TO FIGHT MY FIGHT,
HE'S NOT SOMEONE WHO WANT TO BE
TREATED WITH KIT GLOVES.
HE'S A TOUGH GUY WHO CAN HANDLE
HIMSELF AND HE'S AN AMAZING
PERSON.
>> IT'S EASY FOR THE WHITE HOUSE
TO SAY THAT WAS UNFORTUNATE, WE
APOLOGIZE.
THEY ARE GOING THROUGH A TRYING
TIME.
>> CALL THEM.
LET'S NOT TRY --
>> SHE CALLED MEGAN McCAIN.
SARAH NEEDS TO SAY SOMETHING
FROM THE PODIUM.
>> WE HAVE POLICY DISAGREEMENTS
WITH MSNBC.
HE CALLS THE PRESIDENT AND ACTS
LIKE HE HAS THE MORAL HIGH
GROUND.
SAME THING FOR NICOLE AND THESE
PEOPLE WHO ATTACK ALL OF US
REPUBLICAN WHOSE STAND WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> IT'S DIFFERENT WHEN IT COMES
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU USED TO WORK THERE.
>> MY WIFE WORKS THERE, AND I
DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD SMUDGE
THE CHARACTERS.
>> I'M NOT.
THEY ARE SMUDGING THEIR OWN
CHARACTERS.
>> Laura: MOCKING PEOPLE'S FACE,
IF IT WERE DONE AGAINST ANIS
ISLAMIC INDIVIDUAL, MIKE PENCE
HAS BEEN MOCKED REPEATEDLY BY
THE POPULAR CULTURE THAT ARE
FANS AND FANATICS OF THE LEFT.
IT'S BEEN TOLERATED, IT'S A WINK
AND NOD.
THEY THINK CHRISTIANS ARE
STUPID.
ANYONE WHO SUPPORTS TRUMP IS AN
IDIOT.
I THINK IT'S BACKFIRING.